la parole est à monsieur serge letchimy
monsieur le premier ministre que la mort
de georges floyd a soulevé l'indignation
de milliers de personnes dans le monde
entier
elle met en relief leur racisme
vertébrale les états unis première
puissance mondiale dans les germes
proviennent principalement de l'
esclavage des noirs les nations
d'occident elles aussi se sont enrichis
sous ces mêmes fondations
ce sont ces fondations qui ont créé et
maintenu vivace dans le monde
contemporain leurs assises que l'action
politique ne saurait tolérer
oui contre toutes les violences raciales
la république se doit d'être exemplaire
exemplaires sur l'exigence de justice de
vérité face aux drames humains répéter
comme celui d'amada traoré le racisme
peut être aussi obscur et larvée par la
présence inacceptables de certains
monuments symboles de la période
coloniale
ici à l'assemblée nationale je pense à
colbert le père du code noir par la
parole de celui qui à longueur de tribu
des d'antenne distille impunément la
paix ce qui lui sert d'activité mot
talent je veux parler d'eric zemmour
c'est tout cela qui fait persister un
esprit colonial érigés en système
source d'inégalité d'injustice de
génération en génération
c'est cet esprit colonial qui attisent
des révoltes qui font entendre et qui
exige de bézieux exceptionnel
l'outre-mer est au coeur de ce drame
postcoloniale et justice au quotidien
asphyxie dans la dépendance structurelle
à la tête des administrations dans
l'économie dans les niveaux
d'équipements de santé d'éducation et de
culture dont le traitement des scandales
comme ceux de la chlordécone et j'en
passe la vague planétaire qu'a suscité l
assassinat de floride montrent que la
dépréciation d'une minorité humaine ne
sera plus accepté mais je le voyais
missile est encore temps de donner un
sens à ce principe majeur de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen les hommes naissent et demeurent
libres et égaux en droits c'est en
mettant fin au racisme que nous pouvons
dépasser le dessus sur les espoirs
réparer les factures du présent et
regarder l'avenir en confiance quand
accepterez-vous enfin
d'oxygéner ce pays merci monsieur le
député la parole est un monsieur
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député serge letchimy nous
partageons une conviction le racisme
constitue une plaie le racisme constitue
une plaie ouverte dans notre pacte
républicain
le racisme n'est pas une opinion le
racisme est un délit leur assise mérite
la mobilisation de chacune et chacun
d'entre nous constamment parce que c'est
une vigilance et c'est une lumière qui
implique que nous protégions cette
lumière le racisme doit se voir à l'aune
de la réalité de nos territoires et en
particulier en outre-mer et vous savez
particulièrement pourquoi vous évoquez
cela par rapport à cette histoire mais
c'est notre histoire c'est l'histoire de
la république française qui a ses parts
de lumière extraordinaire mais qui a
aussi ses parts d'ombrés que nous devons
monsieur le député vous avez raison
regardez en face parce que tout l'enjeu
de l'émotion mondiale que nous
connaissons suite au décès de georges
floyd c'est d'avoir la capacité
justement à regarder la réalité en face
à ne jamais la cacher cette réalité à ne
jamais la trahir parce que qui veut la
terre l'a trahi
au fond cette réalité il y a notre
histoire il y à cette part de lumière il
ya cette part d'ombré mais ça n'est pas
ont des boulots non ça n'est pas en
abattant des statuts ça n'est pas en
dénonçant et en cherchant à opposer les
uns et les autres que nous arriverons à
vaincre le racisme c'est plutôt
construisons cette société apaisée cette
société monsieur le député qui osent
regarder dans les yeux sa propre
histoire et ce n'est pas toujours facile
il a fallu sur la seconde guerre
mondiale par exemple que le temps passe
et que l'âge des présidents le
permettent
or le racisme est quelque chose qui nous
touche dans notre histoire qui nous
touche dans notre quotidien et pour
lequel nous devons être totalement
mobilisée et c'est le cas du plan
d'action que le premier ministre avait
présenté en 2018 avec toute une série de
mesures pour lutter contre la
discrimination et c'est le cas
monsieur le député du combat permanent
que nous menons et que je mène
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]